Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. A few people contacted
me about the Circuit City stuff that came up
during my interview a couple of weeks ago with
Patrick about David. Here's one such voicemail.
Speaker 3: Hey David, I saw you on Patrick David's
podcast. Yes, I know you brought up how you
sold the extended service plans at Circuit City,
and I just wanted to hear the story. It sounds
like you want to tell it, and he didn't really
give you a chance, so I was curious. Thanks.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, it's not really one
story, but it was absolute. You know, I've
said before, when I worked at Circuit City,
when I was in high school, it really allowed me
to develop really important interpersonal skills
for quickly building rapport, establishing
a connection with people, getting right to
the crux of whatever it was that brought
people into the store that day. It really
invaluable skills that that I'm so grateful,
even if Circuit City ultimately laid me off,
because they laid off everybody who was selling
too much stuff because they didn't want to pay us
when they switched from commission to hourly.
But one of the most interesting aspects of it
was the selling of extended service plans.
And I've said before that at Circuit City,
if you were reliably selling these service plans,
you could make half to 60% of your income from the
service plans rather than the products themselves.
It wasn't uncommon. I'm going back a ways now,
but just roughly it. What and think about
inflation. This was over. This was 20 years
ago. It wasn't uncommon that if you sold a
computer, you might make $18 in commission,
but the warranty associated with it would pay you
40 bucks if the customer bought it. And we had all
sorts of interesting techniques and ideas. And
everybody always tried to be creative but honest
in order to sell those service plans. And we were
not incentivized to lie because if there was a
problem, the people would come back. That service
plan would be refunded and you would lose the
commission. So there really was not an incentive
to lie. One of the things I would often do is
I would introduce the idea of the fact that
sometimes things break and it's better to
be able to come back to the store than to have to
ship it to, you know, Hewlett-Packard or whatever.
I would introduce it early in the process. And
that made it so that it sort of sold itself so
people would come in, you know, they might
be looking for a laptop as well. Well, what
Why are you looking for the laptop? Mine crapped
out. Really? How old was it? Three years. Really.
And did did you have an extended service plan on
it? No, I didn't. Oh, you know, if. If you did,
it might be covered. You might just be able to get
it fixed. That was my approach. I wasn't coming up
with any, you know, confrontational techniques to
start begging people to buy warranties. I would
just introduce it early. And by the time we would
get to the sales point, I would say, by the way,
I mentioned earlier that if you had had
a service plan on your current laptop,
you might not even need to get a new one. Right
now. It's a relatively small amount of money given
how expensive computer repairs are right now. And
you know, at the time it was much harder to work
on laptops than it is now. So many of the parts
were self-contained and proprietary. Here's what
it is. It really was was that symbol. You know,
there was no there was no big mystery to it.
But it really was about establishing the rapport
and building the relationship with people anyway.
It was a fascinating time and invaluable in terms
of the skills that I learned there. And sadly,
Circuit City decided no more commission. We see
Best Buy paying people seven bucks an hour. Let's
switch everybody to hourly. And then within
months was out. It was out of business maybe,
but maybe like 18 months or something
along those lines. So apparently the wrong
decision. So that was the Circuit City story.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Yes. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Let's make some money, Alex. Let's
do it. We are going to talk about the the reports
that Nikki Haley is reportedly about to announce.
She's running for president in 2024, becoming the
first what we might call major competitor Donald
Trump. Trump is going to lose his mind. Trump and
Haley were friendly during Trump's presidency, but
this is going to trigger Trump and it's going to
be very interesting. We'll discuss that. Secondly,
Alabama Democrats want to ban employers from being
able to force workers to get microchipped. Why is
this even coming up? I will tell you. And lastly,
the College Board is slamming DeSantis, Florida,
for what it is calling slander of the Advanced
Placement Black History course that has been the
subject of so much controversy over the last few
weeks. All of those stories and more when I am
joined by producer Pat on today's bonus show. Sign
up at join Pacman dot com. Don't miss it because
it is going to be a beautiful bonus show.
Unidentified: I will see you next.